claro los seguidores de chivas non que
inteligencia de eeuu dice estaría detrás
de planear este tipo de ataques hoy o el
6 de marzo pues se tienen como fecha el
4 de marzo hoy para que el presidente ex
presidente de donald trump vuelva a la
casa blanca y de ahí que la inteligencia
de eeuu pues ya prendió las alertas
sobre todo en washington sobre todo en
el capitolio para evitar un acto de
violencia parecido a la del pasado 6 de
enero sin embargo la inteligencia no ha
entregado detalles específicos de si
efectivamente es joannon y cuáles son
pues estos detalles del supuesto ataque
violento contra el capitolio usted lo
decía la cama de representantes
pues terminó de votar ayer lo que tenía
pendiente para hoy no asistir a sesiones
precisamente por seguridad y a los
senadores se les ha pedido que por favor
para que en en los parqueaderos
subterráneos de el capitolio para evitar
cualquier contacto con al seguidores que
puedan estar cercanos al capítulo hay
que resaltar
que en la ciudad y cerca de cuatro mil
hombres de la guardia nacional de
seguridad era precisamente para mantener
la seguridad en orden y que cerca al
capitolio pues están estas barreras